chez les dames arrêté non non pas à ça
rigolait vous attendez au début ce beau
gosse sont réglés en six tomes dit la
vérité c'est sur quoi vous est déjà
arrivé un truc en boîte de nuit vous
avez direct non ben oui comme à tous et
non pas comme à tous alors saisir mais
c'est un moment où il a déjà vendu des
roses en boîte de nuit moi par exemple
je dirais pas ça non on galère nous mais
non mais non mais non c'est le par
l'équipage et surtout en boîte il fait
noir à la musique c'est ça qu'on dit oui
les gens me voient quand même et il
devrait pouvoir
j'ai pas mal j'ai pris que des
casquettes en bois de terrain et
collante et ados oui mais aussi
absolument pas mon truc j'avais pas là
cette chose là dedans c'est un petit peu
jobin un peu oui mais je danse mais un
peu comment va pour montrer je danse
pour être avec quelqu'un tu as ce jeudi
repas offert le animal qui attire tu
vois des trucs bizarres comme ça non
vous dansez comeme discrètement comme ça
dans votre coin si je suis avec
quelqu'un mais je vais pas matin encore
une fois à sortir mais plus mais tout le
truc parce que j'y arrive pas on pour y
annoncer un peu avec thé noir ou pas
avec qui avec enora
à l'est de rabat et dont je vais vous
dire que c'est fort les gens râlent et
donc c'est sûr vous les gens et de
musiciens puis sur un bouton comme on
voulait ce que vous voulez quel genre de
musique jean c'est vous qui les sert ici
ce que tu veux adaptable au laisser
aller à l'excès parce que vous le faites
ce que vous les gens je te déteste
et là c'est bon
merci à vous lire je crois que
franchement bel échange entre couches
pouvez pas savoir comme je vous aime
mais vraiment mais on fait le chien mais
pour ce que tu fais vous avez la classe
très bien c'est vrai je vous dirai rien
c'est comme ça j'aime bien il est agile
le genre et dow genre et novateur va
nous chanter une chanson
jean reno est passé au micro main merci
jean reno va nous chanter tout de suite
you are the sunshine non sans vous
inquiétez pas je peux vous demander ça
ne vous choque un peu ou pas mais ça use
the time of my life un truc
ural sinthiang
n'apprécie pas les paroles
là
merci mamie c'est nous
touche pas à mon pote legayic la
solution mais c'est ça le gars il peut
chanter d'après c'est le seul gars qui
peut sauter les sardines au resto classe
alors je voulais les prix ont mis en mi
mineur j'aurais pris ça en ré dièse que
vous voulez